[Music]
[Applause]
boss Tucker our good buddy CBS Westwood
one color analyst and uh he joins us as
usual on Monday host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast also even money podcast
he called Saturday's Chiefs Raiders game
on Westwood one could be found on social
media at Ross Tucker NFL poll question
for uh Ross Tucker Seton
Dan which team surprised you the most
this season in a good way if Jaguars
Giants Seahawks Lions
who would you pick
oh
that's a good one I saw the other one on
social media about who was most
disappointing and I had a really good
answer for that one I didn't see this
one yet
um I would say
probably the Seahawks I thought they
were going to be terrible I mean I
really thought they were going to be bad
bad
I thought Geno Smith would be a disaster
I I got to be honest it's got to be the
Seahawks I mean for him to break the
franchise record for yours I know
there's one more game now but still and
to have the season that he had no way in
heck I thought the Seahawks had any
chance of making the playoffs I think
it's Seattle yeah I think uh we were all
in on Seattle tanking this year and Pete
Carroll proved us wrong Geno Smith
proved us wrong I wasn't surprised with
Detroit because I thought Detroit would
make the playoffs I thought it would be
three teams out of the division uh
little did we know that Green Bay would
not be one of those teams to get in what
did you read into Aaron Rodgers when he
left the field last night if anything
not a whole lot Dan I mean it feels like
this is the third year that we're going
into the off season of the unknown as it
relates to Aaron Rodgers but I think
he's coming back I'd be surprised if he
doesn't now maybe he won't but I think
he's supposed to make like 60 million
dollars I gotta check on that I know
it's a lot of money that is guaranteed
and it's totally up to him if he wants
to come back he's getting that money I
don't think he wants to go out but do
you think the Packers want him back
uh I think they do yes and I also don't
think they have much of a choice let's
put this way
if Roger says he's coming back he's
there because the the financial
implications of trying to trade him are
not tenable so it's really Rogers this
is the first time I think Dan in this
situation where Rogers has really had
all the leverage and all the control and
he knows it I think an interesting
question is whether or not the Packers
would prefer he retires yeah I think
probably not but that's debatable I
think he comes back though because he
doesn't want it to end that way it's 60
million dollars he is very well aware of
his legacy and you know some of the
young guys on defense and Christian
Watson Romeo dabs they started to come
along I think Rogers can look at next
year and say we have a chance to be a
pretty darn good team and actually make
a run how do you explain of the
quarterbacks who played all 17 games I
think there's five or six that played
all 17. Aaron Rodgers is the only one
who didn't throw for at least 300 yards
once in a game
I can't
I didn't even know that until you just
said that five seconds ago so I can't
explain it that's honestly that's
shocking he's clearly not as good as he
used to be I think it's hard to imagine
though Dan that you go from MVP MVP to
that much of a drop off and we still did
see like that throw last night to Watson
it was a great catch by Watson but
Roger's dropping in the bucket he still
has it
I think it was a product of their
receivers and him not being on the same
page and the team electing to try to
lean on the running game but that
surprised me I did not realize that yeah
seven quarterbacks started all 17 of
their teams games this season but Rogers
the only one who didn't have a 300 yard
passing game but then he'll make that
throw to Watson but then he has that
throw at the end the interception where
you're going what was that
it's a great point and you know he
almost had a couple others that were
intercepted by the same guy that guy
that that rookie Kirby Joseph is like
Roger's Kryptonite he's got his hands on
like five or six balls from Rogers in in
two games as a rookie you're right
though we didn't see that with Rogers in
the past you know his interception
numbers were typically so low and I
don't know if he was just trying to make
something happen or forcing it or maybe
in the past he could make a throw like
that and Devonte Adams would make him
right meaning even if he doesn't catch
it would not get away he doesn't have
that same level of trust with these
young guys if you're looking to turn a
small bet into a big payday draftking
Sportsbook same game parlays you can
pocket more cash when you combine
multiple bets in one game download the
app sign up with the code Patrick do you
have parlays for the games coming up
this weekend Ross Tucker I've got two I
like yes I came prepared okay um two
that I like right now one is and it's
plus 250 at DraftKings and for the 49ers
George Kittle one receiving touchdown
and Chris McCaffrey 75 plus rushing
yards
Purdy throws a touchdown pass to Kittle
every game that that's like Kittle is
like Purdy's guy so I feel good about
that the McCaffrey ones a little bit
because they're getting Elijah Mitchell
back I think they'll probably have a
decent lead I don't know that Shanahan
will necessarily get McCaffrey to over
75 yards but I feel pretty good about
that I think the one I feel better about
Dan is the Chargers playing in
Jacksonville Saturday night Justin
Herbert 275 plus passing yards that
seems like a pretty good bet and then
Austin Eckler won rushing touchdown is
plus 275 on DraftKings Austin Eckler
scores a touchdown every game of his
whole career yeah I've never watched the
Chargers game where Echo doesn't have at
least one touchdown now he hasn't scored
it he hasn't scored a touchdown in every
game
no I know I'm exaggerating oh perfect
wow that was great effect there
I'm uh curious what you think of the
Cowboys going into their game in Tampa
after what happened against Washington
how do you how do you shake off a game
like that
I have no idea what either the Cowboys
or the Chargers were doing yesterday Dan
I mean the Cowboys you can a little bit
understand because if the Eagles lost to
the Giants then they would have been
able to win the NFC east and I get that
but it's like scoreboard watch or
something I mean both of those teams
right
they played their starters so their
starters didn't get their rest I think
the quarterbacks came out with like five
minutes left for both of them they got
some guys banged up I sold j-ron curse
go off for the Cowboys Bowser went off
for the Chargers of course the most
notable ones Mike Williams for the
Chargers and they both lost you know I
mean that that's like hitting for the
cycle and like that's you played they
didn't get the rest you got some guys
dinged up and you lost the game they
accomplished nothing you win nothing
couple other things
um you know when you start to look at
the field in the NFC
the team to beat is who
I still think it's the Eagles but I
think the Niners are the best team right
now okay I think that the Niners having
to win in Philadelphia will not be easy
and I know that the Niners are playing
better right now I always wonder like
how much will that mean three weeks from
now when they likely face each other in
the NFC Championship right like if the
Eagles are still kind of not playing at
their best and the Niners are still on a
roll then okay but I don't know I've
just seen it you know when this Eagles
won the Super Bowl in 2017 they barely
beat the Falcons in the divisional round
with foals not looking good and then
they annihilated the Vikings so because
the games in Philadelphia because the
Eagles still have the best roster even
though they haven't finished the regular
season as strongly I still think they're
the team to beat the NFC the team to
beat in the AFC
to Chiefs yeah I mean it's the Chiefs
although I will say this in the AFC no
result then between Bengals bills Chiefs
would surprise me I mean the Bengals had
the toughest road because likely they're
playing first of all they got to play
the Ravens that are going to be at full
strength we think then they got to play
at Buffalo we we think and then if they
win that it would be at Kansas City so
Cincinnati has by far the toughest path
but I think those three teams are are
basically even right now I mean it's a
coin flip that by the way that the
Bengals did not want didn't have to do
but it's a coin flip between Chiefs
bills and Bengals for me right now so
you have to say chiefs because they have
the easiest path you mentioned the
Ravens Lamar Jackson expected back but
this is a guy who's missed at least five
games
in each of the last two seasons I think
and as you move forward with this do you
want to invest 45 50 million dollars a
year in Lamar Jackson
I'm fine with that average I'm not fine
with the DeSean Watson contract right we
know that that's why Lamar didn't sign
what the Ravens offered him he wants a
fully guaranteed deal they're I'm not
I'm just not doing that Dan if I'm the
Ravens I mean I'll if he insists on that
again this year I'll franchise tag him
but I'm not doing that he's missed a
bunch of games the last two years and
the only guy that got a contract like
that to Sean Watson he looks terrible
man I don't think he looks very good at
all DeSean Watson certainly not helping
Lamar Jackson's case neither did Lamar
this year I don't think Lamar had a
great year second year in a row he's
been banged up I I think they won him
there I think they'll offer him 45
million a year maybe they'll even offer
him 50 million a year but it's not going
to be five years fully guaranteed you
just can't do that in the sport of
football especially the way he plays the
position
do you want to go through all of the
games and give me your picks for this
weekend
sure with the spreader no yeah with the
spread oh geez okay I'm not ready for
that go ahead all right I'll see Hawks
Seahawks plus 10 and a half against the
Niners
I'll take the Seahawks 10 and a half's a
lot all right I'll take the Seahawks
Chargers giving one and a half
I like the Chargers to win that game I I
was not overly impressed by the Jags
Saturday night I think that I think the
Chargers win that game I will lay the
one and a half with the Chargers but the
better play there is to take the Jaguars
up to plus seven and a half as one leg
of a two-team teacher we gotta find a
partner with it but the Jag's up to
seven and a half and a two-team
six-point teaser would be the play there
all right dolphins getting 10 and a half
at Buffalo
I hate laying 10 and a half but that's a
game I feel like you almost have to stay
away from Dan till we get some clarity
on quarterback right is there any chance
to a plays or are they shutting them
down I if he doesn't is it Bridgewater I
I stay away until I have some type of
clarity on quarterback I would also
worry about the emotional letdown for
Buffalo like it was so emotional
yesterday against New England it's hard
to match that again now granted I'm
talking about covering not just winning
the game yes but you know so we have to
factor that in the Giants are getting
three at the Vikings
I would take the Giants yeah I mean they
rested their guys
um they played very I mean they lost by
a field goal I think it was overtime
when they played there a couple weeks
ago I think dabo's a heck of a coach
that feels like a field goal game to me
either way so take the three with the
G-Man uh the Ravens getting six and a
half at Cincinnati
boy that's a pretty big unknown with
what we're gonna get from Lamar Jackson
that's a tough one I'd probably take the
Ravens they get Dobbins back they get
Mark Andrews back I think they're going
to be able to keep that one competitive
they're going to run Lamar because there
is no tomorrow I'd probably take the
Ravens and the points I think the
Bengals win but I'll take the six and a
half I don't know the last time Tom
Brady was an underdog at home in a
playoff game but he is against the
Cowboys three
I think I take the Bucks than the three
I think it's gonna be a close game
that's not playing well that doesn't
look good the Cowboys are kind of
limping into this game this this feels
identically to me like the Giants
Vikings where I feel like it's a field
goal game either way so give me the
Bucks getting the three maybe they win
if they don't even if they lose by a
field goal you push good to talk to you
as always Bud we'll talk to you next
week yeah can't wait thank you Dan
that's Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst and uh
gambler